and now on to our first topic the Pope
versus the Vatican in this week's
spectator Damian Thompson reveals what's
really going on in Pope Francis's
pontificate we've seen already that he's
a very charismatic Pope he captures the
attention of non-christians world why
he's come back from a very successful
tour of South Korea but when he's back
in Rome what is he up to
Damian says is nothing less than a
complete overhaul of the Vatican
structure and an attempt to do away with
the influence of the Italian Cardinals
who killed his predecessors papacy
Damian that's quite some stuff you got
in the magazine this week
what to the outsider might be might we
see to a papacy which is being redefined
is this all the internal workings of the
Vatican I think I think the whole point
of this pontificates is to clean up the
Vatican
that is why Cardinal bergoglio was
elected I don't think the Godman
realized that he was going to become
this enormously charismatic figure who
cultivated the press but it is important
not I think to be distracted by lots of
the attention-grabbing
and often contradictory things of
Francis says hinting at you know new
attitudes towards homosexuality or or
marriage they aren't going to happen
it's not on his agenda his big agenda is
he not the Vatican he's basically
declared war on the Curia the Vatican
and particularly the Italian mafia who
destroyed the pontificate of his
predecessor bending the sixteen how do
they destroy the matific 'its well
benedict rather unwisely
put far too much power in the hands of
his secretary state prime minister
Cardinal Bertone II one of the things
but Tony did was that he oversaw the
Vatican Bank but it was far too place
and many of his fellow Cardinals and
bishops and key role officials were far
too close to sleazy
Italian businessman we're talking about
criminality here we're not necessarily
talking about criminality but what we're
talking about is a cozy way of doing
business by you know Cardinals whose
management of money is about skillful as
that of the Reverend Paul flowers of the
coop in this country really big
investment despite everybody
professional advice so the country so
well process is done I think this is
freaked out the liberals a bit is that
he's created a new Vatican Department
which has complete control of the
church's finances and he's put in charge
of it as prefect Cardinal George Pell
was one of the most conservative
Cardinals in the college what changed
Skippy was climate change skeptic I mean
he was head of the church in Australia
and he's come over this new body nobody
will be allowed to to do deals as an
individual and Pell is going to and
everything will be rigorously budgeted
and he'll be advised by highly
successful people from the Anglosphere
now Paul's given interviews in which he
kind of hints that there's a financial
expertise in the Anglosphere that he he
values and he's also said rather
interesting comment that he thought it
was a not necessarily good thing that
Benedict ended up with more Italian
Cardinals when he started the work ethic
coming to Rome I don't think you I think
the house is a touch of the president
work I think about Paul although he
wouldn't like the word Protestant
because the Australian church is it she
very tribal yeah but there's certainly a
work I think there he's he's immensely
clever he's got lots of doctors he's so
much brighter than the vast majority of
Greenland is more drug and spouting
English bishops who are not pretty you
were in room and before the Pope's
elation and and it's funny that nothing
is more political than the Vatican of
that sort of time was there a sense then
that you needed a regime change at the
Vatican which went deeper than just a
new personality that you needed that you
needed a new mechanism and that this
election was about sweeping out an old
order and replacing it within you
definitely definitely I mean you just
had this bombshell of benedict resigning
and everybody I spoke to liberal
conservative tradition is progressive
whatever whatever type of Catholic they
were they were all adamant that the
Curia was the problem something's got to
be done to fix this rot at the heart of
the church and this rot I mean was it
just simply about leaking money I mean
well terrible but doesn't sound that
scandalous well it's always very hard to
get to the truth of it there's there's
always some very you know the Italian
papers will publish this incredibly
sensational stuff about you know kind of
gay mathias and sort of stuff you read
in The Da Vinci Code you know but all
that's exaggerated there's certainly
corruption in there they're sort of
favors being carried out within the
Vatican bankin and then of course
there's the political abuse problem
which was very badly handled by the
Curia for a couple of decades and but
the people I suppose he was quite
interesting as they all thought that
it's such a nativity Italian problem
that you need an Italian to come in and
fix it and then of course we have begun
do who is who was sort of Italian but
he's actually I think he understands
Italians
actually one of his problems is that he
doesn't speak English he's never been to
America that he's gonna go there he's
known me to this country as far as I
know so
in Latin America he is a very figure the
priests he sees evangelizing
successfully all the hands dirty in the
slums tend to be very left with leaning
and and and big ah Leo himself has moved
in that direction having been a very
conservative leader Liberation Theology
he used to clamp down on the Roche
ontology now he favors aspects of it
because he says these are the priests
who work and conserves it in Latin
America you know not very effective or
very nice in the atmosphere in America
and in in Britain and in Australia its
conservative priests who get their hands
dirty who work hard who evangelize and
also who tend to build congregations to
build congregations you know the big
crisis and this has been this has been
confirmed to me by extremely senior
people in Rome in the big crisis in the
English church is that you have a
mediocre and it is the impression that
this is what frustrated Pope Benedict
that he basically decided that he
couldn't do anything with his papacy
because the Curia the guys beneath him
were unbeatable
I mean I was at the impression that the
Pope was an absolute monarch who could
do pretty much what he wanted well he
could just feel a bit let down by the
way Benedict who was really too old I
think great man in many ways great
reformer in liturgical respect he was
really too old when he became Pope he's
also rather kind is called a Rottweiler
not the Rottweiler is the Rottweiler is
Francis not vanity actually and and he
couldn't cope with the escalating
scandals many of which involved people
who were close to him or their deadly
opponents and the factionalism just got
to him and he
books this Pope has decided to bypass
the Italian mafia in Vatican by
appointing a cabinet of Cardinals from
around the world and it's a kind of mess
I think in some ways but it does mean
this change power will be devolved to
individual bishops conferences which if
you look at how awful the English
business conference is may not seem like
good news but actually the non SEOs the
Pope's ambassadors run by the Secretary
of State are pretty useless the
important thing it's been stressed for
me by senior people in Rome is that the
Italians who killed and this is the word
they use killed the pontificate of
Benedict the sixteenth I've gone and
they're not coming back right Freddie I
mean if you're going to be in Rome
taking on Italian Cardinals it's pretty
daunting task isn't it so I mean do you
think Pope Francis stands any more of a
chance than Benedict is well I think yes
and partly because he's got this sort of
huge popular following behind so yes I
think he this is this is a golden
opportunity because there's there's such
a widespread feeling of enough Sanath
the resignation of Benedict was proof
that the system is totally rotten so I
think this is a golden opportunity
whether he can do it is a whether he'll
can do it for him is a difficult
question to answer but Paul's already
done a lot yeah oh my goodness yes I
mean you know he's set up he's I mean
it's not just Pell but these stripped
structures have been set up for him so
how will we know if Pope Francis is
triumph to then and has actually managed
to to sweep out the fueled Curia and get
lots of Argentinians wandering around
instead of Italian we do there's already
lots of Latin Americans wandering around
being making a you know quite a nuisance
of themselves saying oh well we are
simple people you know we're returning
the church to the gospel and this is of
course driving people in the Curia mad
and I can kind of understand what by and
large it doesn't work how we measure
success well actually if you look at
polls department you will see there will
be balance streets you will see where
the money is being generated because
they've got a Joan
in money in order to spend it you'll see
where it is being spent is it being
spent on proper mission and reactivity
on evangelization or is it being
dribbled away on climate change activism
well we see lots of Italians being sort
of well I don't be sidelined lots of
quite a few Italians who advised
financial advisors that were priests
have have been sacked but I think what
we what we will see is the end of a
culture of you know stuffing your face
in the in the in in in a trattoria and
quietly arranging you know the setting
up of a dodgy charity hell was trying to
light onto that that's a great thing if
France can achieve that that's marvelous
do you think and also another thing I
mentioned and just very briefly in in in
if you can reform the Jesuits he'll have
achieved a lot even if as he said this
week I shall be gathered to the house of
my father in three or four years time
which is a typical site using Francis
comment